[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec 10
à oloumi avocat spécialiste défense des
libertés et droits des étrangers
bonsoir il ya oloumi merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés wilfrid donc secrétaire
national du syndicat ufap/unsa-justice
bonsoir à vous et merci d'être là on
lisait des peines lourdes mais pas
maximale une réaction s'il ya ou non mis
sur l'ensemble en tout cas de ce verdict
rendu par la cour d'assises spéciale ce
soir mais c'est visiblement un verdict
mitigé puisque vous avez d'une part d'un
certain dégoût frères qui sont d'accord
avec cette avec la position de la cour
et d'autres qui vont faire appel vous
avez du côté des victimes également de
la la majorité qui sont d'accord avec la
position de la cour
ce qui est important dans ce dans ce
cadre là c'est de distinguer entre ceux
qui ont été reconnus terroristes et les
autres je pense que et tout à l'heure
ces deux pour la france de bien montrer
que dans une justice qui est un peu
médiatisé ben on peut quand même garder
la tête froide et prononcé des peines
qu'ils soient justes pour l'instant doha
visiblement d'après ce qu'on a compris
un appel en grande partie des personnes
condamnées
donc je me réserverai pour la suite mais
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui ça donne
cette impression au regard des trois
mois de hausse et qu' une page se tourne
mais c'est pas terminé
une justice qui n'était pas sous
pression en tout cas qui a rendu justice
à nous disiez à oloumi en substance
wilfried de fond que c'est votre avis
également un procès la hauteur des
événements qui se sont déroulés où c'est
au niveau de l'ufap unsa justice on n'a
pas pour habitude de commenter les
décisions de justice nous notre métier
c'est surtout d'exécuter les décisions
du 6 et aujourd'hui quand on voit les
quantum de peine qui peuvent être
prononcées notamment depuis
2015 on se rend compte que les cantonne
sont de plus en plus élevés avec des
individus qui vont se retrouver
incarcéré pour des 20 30 ans 30 ans pour
certains avec des périodes de sûreté des
deux tiers généralement est donc
derrière la vraie question qui se pose
en tout cas pour nous personnels
pénitentiaires c'est quelle prise en
charge dans quel type de structure alors
justement ça c'est une vraie question
asia onomie parce que on est dans le
cadre d'un procès exceptionnel avec
évidemment des faits d'une gravité
exceptionnelle beaucoup de ces accusés
pour certains en tout cas vont faire des
peines l'imité quelques elle suit pour
eux dans quelles conditions vont ils
être incarcéré de manière favorable en
tout cas en fait si vous voulez ce qui
est important aujourd'hui c'est peu
alors on part d un des confrères parlent
et que la prise de conscience
aujourd'hui nous avons un vrai problème
pour le traitement des personnes qui
sont condamnées pour le terrorisme
donc je disais sans parler de ceux de ce
dossier plus particulièrement parce
qu'il faut collecte dossier précisément
aux conventions annoncé mais en tout
état de cause ces personnes qui vont
faire effectivement 20 ans ne seront pas
bien sûr le représentant du syndicat
pourra le dire également ne vont pas
être dans des quartiers qui sont ô prévu
à cet été pour les terroristes pour ne
pas attaquer les sept autres personnes
et aujourd'hui nous connaissons l'état
de nos prisons
tous les ans des rapports qui sort
récemment les deux nouveaux rapports qui
disent qu effectivement l'état des
prisons sont catastrophiques donc
aujourd'hui de façon les prisonniers de
droit commun sont bleues sont dans un
état particulièrement difficile
donc ces personnes qui arrivent
représente un vrai problème pour
notamment les le personnel pénitencier
parce que il faut savoir les gérer
je disais encore une fois où on aura
sans doute des appels donc dans ce cadre
là pour l'instant
en l'occurrence donc ils seront toujours
considéré comme il ne s'en jusqu'à ce
que la
l'arrêt définitive n'intervienne
éventuellement danser dans cette affaire
mais en tout état de cause c'est un vrai
souci un vrai problème qui se pose à la
fois aux droits parce que dans le droit
alors vous avez résumer ma pensée en
disant que c'était des peines juste je
le disais simplement qu' il fallait
quand même vérifier l'intention parce
que vous avez une partie des personnes
qui disaient qu'ils n'avaient pas
l'intention terroristes or cette intense
en terroriste est un élément car elle
qui caractérise d'infraction donc c'est
important que dans la vie on verra a
sans doute prochainement
tous ces éléments soient caractérisées
parce que sinon ça donne cette
impression qu on a parfois quand on
défendre les dossiers deux entre
guillemets terroriste que le les gibbons
trop vite et ne qualifiez pas les
infractions donc ça c'est déjà un
élément
parce que si ces personnes qui sont
condamnées sont condamnées entre
guillemets donc injustement sans
qualification de ces éléments notamment
l'élément intentionnel et bien vous
allez avoir des personnes qui pourront
toujours revendiqué cette injustice ils
ont ils ont été victimes par nombre
d'injustices et ceci ce n'est jamais bon
même pour les personnes qui sont
condamnées
enfin justement diallo me pardonnez moi
mais la cour a écarté ans a surpris
beaucoup la qualification de terroriste
pour six des onze accusés présents ça
peut étonner
on a peut-être on entend déjà les
détracteurs parlent et peut-être de jeu
de laxisme dans la justice est ce que ça
peut être moi votre avis j'imagine que
non or en fait c'est très simple quand
il s'agit de justice médiatisé
actuellement ce qu'on a on s'attend à
des peines parce qu'on a déjà condamné
ces personnes puisqu'on considère là les
personnes la population considère
souvent que les personnes qui sont
amenés devant la justice ont déjà
condamné
or ces points car le la justice son rôle
c'est justement de permettre aux uns et
aux autres notamment la défense de
produire des éléments qui vont justifier
qu'ils vont démontrer que le parquet ou
le juge d'instruction de grasse n'a pas
effectivement caractérisée
ces éléments de constitutifs de
l'infraction et dans ce cadre là là où
je disais effectivement que les peines
ne pouvait être considérée comme juste
peut-être c'est que les personnes qui
ont été condamnées pour autre chose que
le terrorisme ont accepté la peine et de
l'autre côté les victimes visiblement
ont aussi accepté cette peine là on
verra ce que le parquet fera dans tout
état de cause dans une justice pénale
notamment il faut jamais oublier que ce
qui compte aussi c'est de permettre aux
deux à la fois aux victimes et à la
défense de confort se prononcer et de
d'être content de la sanction qui est
tombé donc il ya l'action pardonnez-moi
willem fond quand on constate que un
accusé comme ça la dsna été applaudi à
son arrivée à fleury mérogis en dit long
effectivement n'at-on pas la crainte de
voir ces nouveaux accusés dans ce procès
être accueillis comme des héros comme
des modèles en prison il est bien
évident qu'aujourd'hui les personnes
détenues qui sont incarcérées pour des
faits de terrorisme bénéficie d'une aura
au sein des établissements
pénitentiaires qui n'est plus à
démontrer maintenant c'est la raison
pour laquelle au niveau du fap unsa
justice aujourd'hui nous demandons à
l'administration pénitentiaire et au
ministre de la justice de prendre en
main les choses et notamment de
respecter les engagements qui ont été
pris en 2018 lorsque la ministre la
justice mais mme belloubet à l'époque
signe un relevé de conclusions dans
lequel elle s'est engagée à créer 1500
places dédiées pour prendre en charge ce
type d'individu aujourd'hui on en est à
450 places en me disant qu'on va rester
à 450 passe donc là dessus c'est juste
pas possible quand on sait que grosso
modo entre les individus qui sont
actuellement incarcérés pour terrorisme
c'est à dire un peu plus de 500 sans
compter ceux qui sont dits radicalisé
mais non terroriste soit 1200 personnes
on en est en haut à plus de 1700 donc
1700 avec 450 places c'est juste pas
possible de pouvoir les gérer ensuite
derrière
il est grand temps également que
l'administration pénitentiaire se
rendent compte que la prise en charge
qui elle propose aujourd'hui c'est à
dire des programmes dits de
déradicalisation ou des engagements de
la violence ne sert strictement à rien
et on va droit dans le mur avec ce genre
de choses
alors qu'elle devrait beaucoup plus se
concentrer sur des choses
plus simple qui est d'empêcher la
diffusion de l'idéologie djihadiste au
sein des établissements
car aujourd'hui la véritable priorité
une urgence c'est celle là c'est comment
l'administration pénitentiaire prend les
moyens nécessaires pour empêcher la
diffusion ce type de ce type de message
au sein des tensions alors lors du
procès en septembre dernier ali riza
paul à la vie les principaux accusés un
qui a d'ailleurs été condamné ce soir à
30 ans de réclusion criminelle a fait
une déclaration un chien qui vous
propose de l'écouter quand je sortirai
de prison
je ferai du banditisme encore plus je
vais faire pire zhihao l'omi quelle
réaction quand on sait d'ailleurs que ce
monsieur ce soir a fait appel ce qui va
ouvrir d'un meilleur la voie à un
nouveau procès quelle réaction quand on
entend ça mais c'est aussi compliqué
parce qu'en fait ce qu'il dit je veux
faire banditisme est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il va être salée comment il allait
encore pire que ça du banditisme est
encore pire
oui ans donc c'est vraiment la vraie
question c'est pour ça que c'est
important que lorsque ces personnes sont
condamnées
s'ils sont condamnés pour le terrorisme
l'ensemble des vêtements des infractions
sont constituées véritablement et pas
avoir ce sentiment que le confrère de la
défense a en disant que le dossier a été
en fait bâclé on a pris effectivement ce
que le juge d'instruction a décidé dans
un premier temps et non la paix collait
si c'est bien ce que j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure donc il faut absolument que la
justice prenne son temps pour donner cet
élément là et pourrait ensuite le ce que
dit ce monsieur en disant je vais
continuer le banditisme
c'est un vrai souci qui a été rappelée
ci c'est un vrai terroriste un vrai
terroriste il doit être traité d'une
certaine façon il peut pas être traité
comme les autres qui va pas attendre les
sondes aux logiques si effectivement la
personne a fait exploser ou là à tirer
sur des personnes quand même 17 morts
donc cette personne ne va pas s'arrêter
d'un coup
par contre je me dis s'il parle de
banditisme et de pierres ça voudrait
dire que il disait qu'il n'avait pas
participé à un acte de terroristes et
dans ce cadre là c'est un vrai c'est
vrai difficulté on sait très bien que
des personnes qui sont condamnées même à
30 ans avec une peine de sûreté des deux
tiers
quand ils sortent le problème c'est pas
de rentrer c'est leur sortie et
là-dessus le personnel pénitentiaire
n'est pas pour la plupart alors ça a été
rappelé tout à l'heure
450 personnes ne tenez pas n'a pas
suffisamment d'encadrement connaissances
pour pouvoir les traiter
donc je pense que là dessus c'est un
vrai problème que le terrorisme posent à
la société française et à notre justice
y compris la peine merci beaucoup à tous
les deux
viens aux limiers wilfried d'un fonds
d'avoir été avec nous